[Music]
mr. Spade I'm told that you you
irritated Adele
yeah one of the biggest super one of the
biggest superstars on the planet anywa I
rubbed her wrong you rubbed you the
wrong way what did you do to Adele um so
I did a backflip during the commercial
yeah I was it he does it every Memorial
yeah I was at a restaurant eating and
then I see it they all come on this
beautiful singer you know yeah and a
huge fan so I go my friends you could
have just given her a thumbs up huge fan
and kept eating no she shouldn't see me
though okay
so but my friends go are you gonna talk
for I go I don't do that I get it I'm in
the game you know you leave people long
again but then a couple knocks later I
go should we matter if I don't say
something yeah ha ha I got a little
loudmouth soup in me and I you know then
she's a bodyguard so I feel like he's
like I've explained I'm famous no I
don't a lot of stuff you know I go
Benchwarmers not all the time surprised
you see you're explaining her security
guard that you were a noon store sort of
yeah yeah and then I go in there and I
don't say hello like a cornball I go
what ha you know I go like the Budweiser
commercial you know you like the story
yeah we had dinner before once now tie
you into the story so um and then uh
she's on my phone out and your eyes are
darting like I might be going for a
selfie so I put it back in the holster
you know I mean I don't want to make her
nervous but then I blab like this story
I stayed about four minutes too long I'm
talking to her and then I go next time
let's do this at my house of a huge
backyard I didn't know what I'm saying
through it you're just babbling at
addling I like this yeah and so I just
kept doing it and then as she sort of
glazed over and then I I think I tiptoed
out I don't know what happened what do
you want to happen yeah I don't really
know do you think you guys are gonna
have a great experience together no I
thought maybe she'd invite me to England
to stay for a month
I've never gone something can be an
absolute fool of yourself
yeah and turns out she didn't see
grown-ups she didn't seem to shoot me I
went through my whole resumes yeah yeah
I'm how familiar I think the satellited
they bound about that how did you did
you have your David likes to drink and
when he drinks he keeps it in a sock
with oh I didn't have my sock I favorite
I got my phone in my sock though yeah he
does go sock pocket yeah I go that's why
I put the airplane bottles but I that
place I had it I had a real shot you boy
yeah and I like Yahoo um but anyway all
right in other news by the way yeah
shinai ders mad at me so I have to
bronchitis mad at him because he was
dopey David and talking about him yeah
so I'm gonna apologize to Adele and Rob
mostly Robbie Robbie sorry
where's my camera yeah cause I don't
believe you corrosion oh no I'm sorry
Robbie we're buddies we had a great time
on the tour so far and I know we can cut
this out yeah it's all just not no one's
ever going to see this I really don't
know what I'm scared about yeah you're
Conan
you